サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
えっと 今日はスライドを作ってないので
そのままお話を進めていきます
そこでまあ私は決まって聞き取れない
間違った発音とかなまりとかね
結構持ってますので そういう誤解しやすい言葉とかは
哲郎さんがスクリーンに映り出す可能性はあります
約束はできません では
まあ結局は暑いんですから
難しい話はね あまりよくないと思います
ですから できるだけ軽く
話したいとは思います
今日のテーマは違うって素晴らしいっていう
という智慧の道なんですね
いきなり結論から始まります
違うってすごい素晴らしいんですよ
なんで我々はものすごい色んな苦しみやら悩みやら文句やら不平不満
あれやこれやと思ってるんですかね
世の中で 世界は違うものであると理解できないんですね
自分のプログラムにすべて合わせようとしているんです
これはもうありえないんですよ
二人が何かちょっと喧嘩することになったら
お互い相手が悪い 私の言う通りに認めなさい
信じなさい やりなさいという態度なんですね
これは決してありえないと
仏教的な立場なんですね
だから いかなる我々の生きる上で起こる問題であろうか
この 特に社会に関するね
問題っていうのは すべてこの違いは認めないから起こるものなんです
それで違いということを認めたら
ここですごい穏やかな
清らかな 楽しい世界が直ちに現れます
だから仏教ではそういう変な超自然珍秘とか何もないで
もうすごい具体的で それぐらいは誰にだってできるでしょうに
何者でも違うんだと 同じものはないんだと
違うって当たり前やと
それは変えられることできませんと
余計なことやと それってそれで違うを違いを楽しむ人がずっと楽しく生活するんです
だから我々は日常的にはこの楽しくない
あれってちょっと気持ち悪いとか思うかもしれませんが
それはもう気持ち悪いって思った時点で
自分にはこうであるべきという姿が頭の中にあるんですね
人の形はそうであるべき
私が作った形に合ってないんだから失格やと
そういうことでも気持ち悪いと言ったりするんですね
だから世の中を見ながら面白いと楽しいというよりもね
結構面白いと思った方が直ちに今日から
今から人生は楽しくなるんです
すべて精神的なストレスあれやこれやとかなくなってしまいます
いたって簡単な道なんです
はい この結論です それからなんでこんな結論するのかと説明していきます
で 次に同じポイントを続けますけど
この社会的な悩みが消えるんだと
では 個人で一人で悩んでいるものは何なのかと
それはほとんどこうであるべきのに
こうでこういう風になっていないという自分の内の中の戦いなんですね
自分一人で悩んでる場合は
まあそれは社会のことだったら
そこはここで解決した方がよろしいし
例えば自分が怠け者ですから
まあ嫌だこれはとか 自分が怒りっぽいだからね
ああ 困ったな これは とかね
そういう風にまあ自分がもう何やっても失敗するわとか
どうもどうも 私が何か希望して計画を立てて実行しようと思ったら失敗するわとか
そういう風にも自分のことで悩んでるしている場合でも
もう同じ法則なんですね
結局は 怒りっぽいは良くないんだと
偉そうに自我張ってるんです
自我張ってるんだから
怒りっぽいは直らないんですね
怒りっぽい性格にさらに怒ったりするんですね
だから まあ素直にあ 怒りっぽいですね
私はと そういう性格ですと
そこで その人との違い
自分の違いを見た方がいいんです
他の人とはうまく物事をやって成功しているかもしれませんだけど
あ 私は失敗する人間だなとかね
なるほど 私がやったらこれは失敗するとかね
そういう違いなんですね
そう見ると また自分の心の中が落ち着いていくんですね
だからといって怒るのがいいわけじゃないし
欲張ることもよくわけじゃないんだけど
それはもう全部同じ問題ですけど
だからといって このいい加減無理やりかっこつけて直そうとしても
それは直りませんよ 直すためには
この今日のテーマはね
いろんなテーマで喋ってますけど
この違いってすべては違いますと
それは素晴らしいと見なくちゃいけない
だから我々は物事は違うということで素晴らしいと見る能力を
これからどう育てるのかと見てみましょう
はい 最初に最初のポイントはこれじゃなくて
よくこの前もゴータミーで喋りましたけど
すごい単純なポイントなんで
これ仏教用語で 特に日本仏教
大乗仏教で使っている単語は 3つありますね
あの差別 区別 分別という
その 3つを勉強していきましょう
で 差別 分別 分別っていうのは
私たちがやる何か一つの仕事なんですね
で それってどういうことかと
説明は差別 区別 分別なんですが
説明は真ん中から始まります
区別って何なのかと 区別っていうのは
一切の現象は 現象 それぞれ違いますと発見する能力なんです
このAとBは違いますと
どこが違いますかと あ
こういうこういうところ違いますと
発見しなくちゃいけないんですね
で それは 区別というんです
リンゴとミカンは違いますね
それ違いますと分かりますね
それは区別能力なんですね
で ということは違うって素晴らしいという言葉にテーマで行くならば
我々はどんな能力を育て育てた方がいいんですかね
区別能力 育てなくちゃあかんですね
区別する力が強ければ強いほど
ものの微妙なさまで分かっていくんです
区別能力ない人がリンゴとミカンって同じやということでね
取っちゃうと困るんですよ
だって食べるものだったらね
間違ったものを食べたら困るでしょうに
リンゴを食べるべきでしたのに
ミカン食べちゃったらね
それはちょっと違いますよ
何でもいいんだから食べなさいということも成り立たないでしょ
だったら土とかね 葉っぱとか紙とか食べちゃってもいいんだからね
やっぱり区別能力が必要なんですね
そこで これはこの我々の学問世界なんです
物事を学ぶときは 我々は何を身につくかというと
区別能力なんですね 区別能力が上がると知識も上がっているんです
だから ちっちゃな子供たちは
この何か書き物 ボールペンなんか持ってごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ書くんだけど
何の餅にも何もなってないんですね
ただ大人が書いてるんだから
本人も書きたくなっちゃって
ボールペンを取って ものすごい力強くそれ取って
紙ももう破れるぐらい力強く書くんだけど
もうなんかごちゃごちゃ落書きにはならないんですね
子供の子供も書いたと喜んじゃいますけど
でもじわじわとこの子供は
この書く線の区別を学んでいくんですね
そこでやっとひらがななんかいくつかの文字を書けるようになる
それでまたどんどん発展して
あらゆる文字を書けるようになる
そこで自分が書いた文字と他の世間にある文字を比較して違いわかったところで
よりきれいな字を書けるように訓練する
だから 文字を書けるということは肉体的な訓練なんですが
知識で区別能力によって体の細胞が変わっていくんですね
というわけで 区別能力っていうのはとても必要なものなんです
それがないと命は成り立たない
ですから この区別能力はすべての生命にあるんです
カラスは間違ったものは食べません
間違ったものを食べてお腹を壊しましたと
食中毒で死にましたとかね
それはカラスたちの動物の世界ではないんです
そのその生命は 世の中はみんなにオープンだからね
カラスにもスズメさんにも
もう他の動物たちにも世界はオープンなんですよ
キツネさんにもね クマさんにも
森はオープンです しかし
面白いでしょう キツネさんは森にあるものは何でも食っちゃえということはないんです
鳥たちも もう森にあるものは何だっていいやと食っちゃいます
それはないんです クマさんも何だって食べますよってことはないんです
ちゃんと区別能力があるんです
だから 何を食べて何を食べてはいけないか
区別能力はある どこに住んでどこに住んではいけないかという区別能力はある
巣を作る場合は どこら辺に作った方がいいかということは
その区別能力がある それで何か見えてくるんですかね
輪廻転生する生命には
どこに生まれても その命をつなげるために必要な区別能力はインストールして現れるんです
生まれる時 赤ちゃんにインストールしているんです
区別能力は 猫が生まれると猫にもインストールしているんです
プログラムは入っているんです
だからまあ何がしかは生きていられます
ということは このプログラムを誰がインストールするかというと
その人の業なんです 神様ではないんです
だから ある区別能力を入れたところで
心に犬としてしか生活できない
そうすると犬で生まれるんです
なんで心が犬の生命になるのかというと
その心に入れた区別能力が犬の世界でしか使用できません
だから犬になる 心に...心みんな同じです
心にインストールした区別能力が猫の世界なら大丈夫だったら
その生命は猫になる ですから
世の中で我々が知っているのは動物世界だけですけど
あの みんなそれぞれの命をね
それぞれの肉体を死ぬまで維持管理できる程度の
まあ基本的な手当はもらっているんです
それは業というんです
しかし 面白いことがあるんです
この区別能力をインストールしてあるんだからといって
これを拡大することはできます
能力を上げることはできます
能力を上げるとどうなるかというと
生きる範囲はもうちょっと広くなる可能性はあります
例えば野生の動物は 人間は怖いんだから逃げなさいという区別能力は入っているんです
人間たち近寄ってくると殺されます
だから動物は違う種類同士でも仲良くします
カラスの群れ 鳩の群れの中にスズメもいることはできます
あまり問題ないんで怖がらないんです
まあカラスはもうヤクザだからね
まあ逃げるんだけど でも時々上のとかね
鳩の餌あげるところにカラスも降りてきて食べたりする
別にカラスが見たら鳩たちが怯えて逃げるっていうこともないんですね
しかし どんな生き物も人間だけには近寄らないんですね
蚊以外は で なぜかというと殺されます
蚊もそんな運命になりますけどね
しかし 野生の動物でもちょっと区別能力を広げて
必ずしも人間が動物を殺すっていうこともないんじゃない
人間っていうのは 動物を見つけては殺す
見つけては殺すっていうことはしていないんだと
だからちょびちょびと近寄ったってもいいんじゃないかと言って
ちょっと近寄ってもらうと
その動物は自分の区別能力を広げたんですね
広げたところで人間に可愛がってもらって餌までもらっちゃうんですね
それで人間が名前までつけちゃって
もう餌なんか用意してもう呼ぶんですね
呼ぶとちゃんと来る えらい動物の中でなんか格好上がったんですね
あの動物の 私はある人がね
カラスに餌をあげることを見ていて
まあ初めは人間のことを怯えてたんですけど
それで毎日餌もらってるんだから
だんだんカラスたちはすごく馴染んで
まあすごい気持ちよく
あちらこちら枝に座ったりして餌をもらったりするし
で いなくても一羽もいない時でも
餌を持って呼んだだけで
あちらこちらから来るんですね
声聞いてさっさと だからカラスたちが自分の区別能力範囲をちょびっと広げただけで
結構生きる範囲も広げていくらか生きやすくなったんですね
ということで 私たちはではなくて
生命は区別能力を広げるならば
生きる範囲が縄張りが広げていくんですね
生き方もどちらかというと便利になるかもしれませんね
はい この様々な梵天から地獄の生命まで
生命はたくさんいるんです
その中で この一般的な何しかね
欲の世界という言葉がありますね
欲世界 欲世界っていうのは
あの まあ地獄も入りますけど
もう神々までね もう一つ一般的な単語があります
カーマローカとパーリ語で言います
カーマローカ 欲世界欲界
この欲界にいる生命には
生まれる時インストールした区別能力を広げることはできます
しかし 無制限ではないんです
無制限に広げるということはあり得ないんです
誰にだってあるリミットがあります
そこは飛び越えないんです
それで私たち犬猫を飼ってますね
この我々飼っている犬猫の区別能力は野生の犬猫とは違いますね
今は現在野生の犬はいないんだけど
インドだけいるんですね
野生の犬 で 面白いことは
野生の犬は森に住んでないんです
インドの地方に来たら
いくらでも犬たちがいる
あれ 誰一人も飼ったことがないんです
放し飼いではないんです
カラスやら他の動物たちも同じくいるんだけど
違うところはいつでも人間いるところにいる
人間から離れて野生に戻ろうということはやってないんですね
まあそれだけで やっぱり長い間飼ってきたんだから
区別能力がちょっと違うんですね
野生の犬だったら狼と同じ態度を取らなくちゃいけないでしょ
狼と狐とかね 同じ種類だからね
犬だから 狼も犬で狐も犬でしょうに
しかし 犬という種類はもうなかなか人間に飼われちゃったんだから
なんで狼を飼わないで犬を飼っている？なんで狐さんを飼わないで
人間が昔から犬を飼ったんですかね
すべての人間 教育なんで
これは区別能力なんです
狐さんよりは犬の方が区別能力は簡単に広げちゃったんです
それで人間に愛されちゃったんです
ね 例えば 人間が馬に乗るんだけど
シマウマには乗りませんね
シマウマに荷物荷車運んでもらうことはしません
あまり走れない動物ですけど
でも馬は馬ですからね
何ですかというと 馬は調教できたんですね
調教できたっていうことは
馬の区別能力が広げちゃったんです
シマウマは無理なんです
学びません どう考えても
馬の背中に人間に乗るっていうことはおかしいでしょうに
馬から考えれば 馬は走れるんだけど
何か荷物運ぶ背中に乗せて
そんなのは馬の人生にはいらないものなんですね
でも 人が乗っても何のこともなく
人が言うところに運んであげる
それは馬さんが学んだんです
勉強したんです それで馬の区別能力が広げたんです
それで人間が馬を飼ったんだけど
シマウマは飼いません
はい それで人間に飼われて馬はひどい目に遭ったりもしますが
結構楽に生きているでしょ
かって考えてみれば だって野生でいたら
誰が体をきれいにブラッシングして
高価な色シャンプーつけて
あんなものをやってくれる？だってノミとか1匹もないでしょ
人間飼ってる馬の体には
もう私たちの皮膚よりもすごい綺麗ですね
皆様の髪の毛よりですか？美しいのは馬の毛
馬の方がピカピカでしょ
だから馬にしてみればまんざら悪くないでしょう
人間を家来にしているんだから
仕事をしなさいと おいよ
餌を持ってこいと 言わないんだけど
その態度でしょ 食べて終わったら
はい これ綺麗に綺麗にしなさい
だから人間が馬が飼っているか
馬にケラーにされてるか
どちらかよくわかりませんね
で 犬のことを言いたいのは
犬もそうでしょう それで犬の区別範囲が広げると
私たちはなおさら犬のことをかわいいんですね
だってバーンと言ったら犬が転がってくれるならば
はい お手お手と言ったら手を出してくれるならば
お座りと言ったら座ってくれるならば
輪っかを見せて飛べと言ったらちゃんと輪っかで飛んでくれるならば
まあむちゃかわいいでしょう
新聞は玄関に捨てた 捨てたところで
配達さんにね ワンちゃんがさっと出て行って
そこを口にくわえて持ってくるならば
はちゃめちゃかわいいでしょ
その犬は ということは
犬は何か学んでいるんです
その分 犬の人生は楽になる
より一層可愛がってもらう
イギリスのあの このリアリティ番組を一つ見たんですけど
そこはこの動物出す番組で
ある女の人がこの犬とのいろいろ仲良くするいろんなことを見せたんですけど
腰が抜けるほどびっくりするんですね
この犬たちやっていることを見て
犬 2匹でしたけど だから彼女は 1万ポンド
1万じゃなくて 100万か
すごい金額もらっちゃったんです
100万じゃもっと上ですね
ワンミリオンと言うんだからね
で 彼女はあれぐらいお金をもらったのは
この犬たちが 言うことをちゃんとやるんだからなんです
で 言わないんだけど このちゃんとパフォーマンスをするんですね
そこでストーリーも作って
面白かった ものすごく面白かった
そこで私が言いたいのは
その 2匹の犬はいろんなことを余計なことを勉強しちゃったんです
犬にとっては可愛がってもらうだけなんですけど
飼い主ももう 100万ポンドか 1,000万ポンドとかもらっちゃって
もう大金持ちということ
はい では人間世界に戻る前にワンポイント
あの場面で出た犬は この何かこのえっと
道具 何か修理屋さんの演技があって
いろいろ道具があってね
そちらに犬もいるんですけど
犬はもう尾っぽで引っ張るんですね
引っ張ってもカチッと止まってこないんですね
そこでわかったということで
でっかいこの磁石のような道具なんですけど
磁石はもう尾っぽの後ろの方につけちゃう
つけて後ろにする 犬が何のことなく後ろに行くんですね
後ろを見ようとしない
このまま後ろに引っ張られているように演じる
演じるんです これ 相当難しいと思いますよ
だってあれ 体につけてないんです
あの道具は 磁石のように作った何かものでしょうね
もう紙で作ったものかもしれません
でも舞台でちゃんと演じるんですね
磁石に引っ張られたような感じで
ですが 犬が後ろ 後ろ 後ろに行くんで
それは私にとってすごく面白かったんです
それで何か間違いを犯しちゃって
逮捕するんですね まとめに逮捕されたんだけど
自分が鍵を開けて出ていくんです
出て行って本人が見るとまた中にいるんです
ここまでやると もうあの女性がね
すごい金額もらえて金持ちになるのは仕方がない話なんですね
はい それであのぐらい頭のいい犬であろうとも
2 たす 2 は教えられるのかと
3 かける 3 は教えられるのかと
ごまかしできますよ でも教えられませんね
だからリミットがあるんです
時々犬も人間の言葉をしゃべろうとする場合あるんですよ
うまくいかないんですよ
そちらリミットがあるんです
はい それから人間に戻りましょう
我々人間も区別能力を育てていく
人間として このインストールしたプログラムでは生きていられないんです
なぜならば 人間が生まれると
剛で猿程度の 能力しか遺してないんです
しかし まあ育てなければどうそうと
業がその自由は与えているんです
だから これイメージで考えます
赤ちゃんが生まれる この赤ちゃんに
まあ何かミルクをあげますけど
人間の社会にある文化
何一つも教えない 人間と顔を合わせることもさせない
それで大きくなったら
その人間はどうなるんですかね？お箸使える？使えません
言葉喋られる？喋れません
猿は手で取って食べるんだから
その人にもご飯をあげたら手で取って食べるかもしれません
では 本人独立して自分で生活しなさいと言ったところでご飯炊けますかと
人間の文化知らないでしょ？炊けません
そうすると野生あちらこちら走ってトウモロコシを見つけたら
そのままトウモロコシを食べるんであって
これを料理することはできない
ということは全く猿に戻るんです
そこで人間は猿ではないんですね
我々は文化というものを作ったんで
この私は文化っていうのはすべて
芸術だけじゃないんです
建物を作ることを科学
すべて文化なんです 人間が作ったものなんです
そこで人間が文化というものを作ったんですが
それは区別能力なんです
学校に行って何を学ぶかというと
みんな勘違いしています
数学を学んでいるんだ
国語を学んでいるんだとかね
だから教育システムはあまりうまくいかないんです
人間が数学国語を学んでいるわけじゃなくて
区別能力を上げているだけなんです
ですから 学校で学ぶものは仕事に役に立たんとかね
くだらんことを言ってるんです
外国で研究したんだけど
こんなのは会社に入ったら要りません
だから初めから嫌な勉強やめた方がいいんじゃない？とかね
そういうふうに言う人間いるでしょ
あれは教育システムの間違いなんです
何を学んでも何かしら役に立つ
例えば 日本の若者がスワヒリ語を学んだとします
スワヒリ語って思い浮かんだんだから言ったんだけど
もう名前まで知らない言語あるでしょ
世の中で 苦労して苦労してそれ学んだんですよ
しかし 日本の会社にあんた何かできる？スワヒリ語できる
役に立ちませんね ではないんです
そのスワヒリ語を学ぶ過程で
その人は区別能力身につけているんです
それが役に立つ です というわけで
何でもいいんだから勉強した方が役に立ちます
それによってその人は区別能力を育てます
役に立つのは区別能力なんです
学んだその内容じゃないんです
だって数学の場合は 学校で教える数学っていうのは余計でいらんものばっかりなんです
実際の世界ではそんなややこしい数学は通じません
いりません それは宇宙研究する
そういうところにだけ必要なものなんです
衛星を伸ばすとかね サテライトを動かすとかね
で そんな世界には厳しい数学がいるんだけど
普段いらない いらないんだけど
なんで苦労してあのややこしい数学を教えるのかというと
それだから区別能力ついてくるんです
だから数学者が料理の勉強をしようと思ったら
いとも簡単にやっちゃいます
で 数学と音楽はものすごい畑が違うんだけど
数学家はいとも簡単に音楽家にもなれるんですね
だから数学を学んだ区別能力を生かしちゃうんですよ
だって音楽の音を数学で考えれば数学ですからね
楽譜を数学で読めばいいでしょうに
このこのこの波長やと
だから本人は楽譜のあれはもう波長論でいっちゃえば
で 演奏できるんです はい
それで私たちは生まれつきついてきた区別能力をもう育てていく
皆様に一つ言います 人間にはインストールしていると言ったでしょ？赤ちゃん見てください
赤ちゃん何も学んでないでしょ
でも赤ちゃんがものの見事に生きる技を知っているんです
どうすればお母さんが自分のことを可愛がってくれるかと
どうしたらお母さんが飛んできて自分の面倒を見てくれるのかと
これは知ってるんです
皆様できると思いますか？これは赤ちゃんにおっぱいを吸い方を教えるとか
教えられませんよ 赤ちゃん
それ知って生まれるんです
こういう風に吸いますよと教える必要ないんです
おっぱいを吸う時は できるだけお母さんを握ったり捕まったりしてくださいと
その信号でお母さんの愛情が生まれて
おっぱいが簡単に出ますよと
教えられる？教えられません
でも 赤ちゃんはおっぱいを吸う時はどうやってもお母さんのおっぱいを握っているんです
何か捕まえるものをずっと握っているんです
だから ある程度で生まれるところまで必要なプログラムはインストールして生まれるんです
はい それで我々はあらゆる区別能力を育てていく
区別能力があればあるほど
我々の我々の知識がすごいんです
古い何かも破片一つ見て
工学的な区別能力だったら何か分からないでしょう
これは何々時代のなんだらかんだらとかね
わからないんです ただ
私は化石一つ拾ったら区別能力があるんだから化石やとはわかってます
でも何時代の何者かとはわからないんです
もし私はそういう古いことを学ぶことを勉強していたならばわかります
知らない 何か変な化石を見つけた
これはどういうものかと知りたくて
知りたくなったら 我々は博物館どこかに行ってそれを見せて
こういうものを見つかったんだけど
これどういうものか そっちの区別能力があるんだから
調べてこういうものですと
この生き物でしたと この時代でいたんだよと教えてくれる
だから区別能力とは知識世界なんですね
そこで仏教は区別能力を否定するかというと
否定しません 学びなさいとずっと言ってるんです
学ばなかったら猿なんです
次のポイント 区別能力とは
何でしたっけ？差を知ることなんです
違いを知ることなんです
もし世の中違うものでできてないならば
知識はありえないんです
どんな現象も互い違うんだから
知識深めるチャンスなんです
たとえ我々はそれほど鋭くないんだから
このホールの椅子を見ると
同じデザインで同じ色で同じ規格で作った椅子やと思っちゃうでしょ
椅子を外して外へ出したら
どんな列のどんな椅子ですかとわかりますかと
わかりませんね わかりません
ということは そこまで区別能力は進んでないんです
だいたい椅子にこうホールなんかだったら
こちらが振ってるかどうか
番号は振ってるんですね
番号があったらわかります
何列で何番かとね じゃあ番号がない場合は
この椅子を全部一個一個外してみたら
もうわからないんです
では これを見てください
この椅子 一個一個違うんです
工場で品質を同じくしようかと頑張ったんだけど
こちらの椅子に貼ってる赤いポスト
なんてか革貼ってますね
それと隣のものって違うもんだからね
では これ想像しましょう
ある人がいる この人が一遍すべて椅子を見る
見てからその椅子を全部外して外へ出す
出してから元に戻ってくださいと
その人には椅子 あ これは 3番目の何々とかね
これは A列の 7番目 これは C の 8番目とか言えるならば
どれぐらい能力ですかね
怖いほど区別能力なんですね
皆様はジグソーパズルできますね
なんでできる？これとこれが違うってことでしょう
だからできるんです だから違いとは
面白いだけじゃなくて
それが現実なんです それに戦うんじゃないんです
それを学んですごい頭のいい人間になるだけなんです
しかし 私たちにはリミットがありますよ
いくらなんでも この椅子を全部一つ一つよく勉強して
この列のこの椅子やと確認するまでの違い
データが我々の脳には入りません
本当のところ それ犬にできますね
犬にできます 犬にはその区別能力があるんです
だから犬にできないのは
これを人間に示す方法を持ってないんです
だって犬は目ではなくて匂いだから
だから匂いで各椅子は自分の匂いを持ってるんです
だって座る人々も数変わってるでしょうし
ずっと同じ椅子に同じ人間が永久的に座るってことはありえないでしょうに
だから犬にだったら匂いで区別することができると思います
でも人間には無理 はい
それで区別について結構喋りました
なんで人間に知識があり得るといえば
物事は違うんだからなんです
現象はすべて違うからなんです
似てないからなんです
そこで我々の愚か者だから
水といえばどこでも水一つやと思ったりする
でも 一滴一滴の水を作られている酸素と水素でしたっけ？これ違うんだから
微生物的には自分の存在は特別にあるんです
私たちにわからないんだから
一緒にしちゃうんです
それで我々のアホらしさがあまりにもひどい場合は
次の言葉に行きます 差別に行くんです
違うものは 軽蔑するんですね
侮辱するんですね 差別とは罪です
それは区別に自分の判断を入れるんです
良いものと悪いものと
物事に良いもの悪いものと判断つけると
その人はバカに決まってるんです
何も学ばないんです 物事は違うんであって
良い悪いとは判断できません
そこで自分より背が高い人をバカにするは
自分より背が低い人をバカにする
バカにして自我を いわゆる無知を
強くするんですね だから差別は犯罪で罪です
で  あまり長く喋っちゃうと面倒くさいんだからね
分別 3番目の言葉 で 分別の場合はどちらかというと選ぶことなんですね
選ばなくてはいけないんですね
この選ぶ能力は分別なんですね
だから区別がなければ分別は成り立ちません
自分の体の状況は 今日はどんな状況かと
それよく区別能力があって
食べるものがいくつかあって
そちらにもすごい区別能力があって
今日は何食べるのかと選ぶ
それは分別能力なんです
いわゆる行うべきことと行ってはいけないこと
判断する能力は分別なんですね
この場合は残念ながらね
それは育てなくちゃいけないんですね
あの インストールしているプログラムはないんですね
そこでこの我々仏教を学ぶということでもやっているのは
この分別能力を 育てていきます
分別を育てるためには区別は必要です
だから両方育てていきます
例えば 心には様々な感情が現れる
あって悪くない感情もあったらいけない感情もある
そこで分別ない能力ない人は
そのまま動物のように生きてみる
怒りが現れたら怒りのまま
欲が出たら欲のままで生きるというくだらないことをやっちゃうんですね
分別能力ある人は 私は怒っちゃいましたけど
怒りは使うものではない
と その感情を使わないことにする
で 殺したってでも殺したいと気持ちが生まれたんですけど
その意欲は 使ってはいけませんというふうに
この選ぶ能力 わかりやすい言葉では道徳世界
倫理世界 分別から生まれるんです
区別だけでは道徳は成り立たないんです
犬猫には道徳はないんですよ
倫理はないんでしょう
犬猫もね やってはいけないことをやらないし
やりたいことをやっちゃいますし
あれは区別能力だけの話なんですね
だから我々は倫理世界
道徳世界も分別能力で育てていくんです
そのためにもものは違うでなければ成り立ちません
例えば 物惜しみとお布施っていうのはまるっきり同じことやと
それだったら成り立たないでしょう
心の働きを見ると 物惜しみの働き状態と寄付するときの働き状態は随分違います
それで結果も変わるんです
それで人はどちらを選ぶのかと選ばなくちゃあかん
だから物惜しみをやめて寄付する気持ちを育てる場合は
それは倫理世界 道徳世界なんですね
で なんでそういうふうに選ばなくちゃいけないんですかね
それは結局はね 人間は幸福になりたいんです
死にたくはないんで 生きていきたいんです
それは基本的には幸福に生きていきたいという気持ちがあるんだから
まあそれに合わせて倫理が成り立ってくるんですね
だから生きていきたいということは
大したことじゃなくないんだから
仏教はそうではなくて
幸福になりなさいという目的で生きてみてくださいと
なぜならば 生きていきたいということには頑張らなくてもいいんです
人間がいらんことに頑張っているんです
あの井戸をいっぱいにしたいと思って
井戸に水を汲んであげる
これいらんことなんです
すごい苦労して大量の水を井戸に入れたら
井戸の水がいっぱいになるかもしれませんだけど
たちまち元のレベルに戻るんです
皆さんはあまり井戸を見たことがないんだから
面倒くさい この例えは
サラナンガラさんは見たことあると
今スリランカに住んでいるんだからね
井戸には水レベルがずっと決まってるんです
それはこの英語でウォーターベッドと言いますけど
土の中に水があるんですよ
そちらに合わせて井戸の水のレベルが決まっているんです
地下水の状況によって
そこである馬鹿がいっぱい機械持ってきて
大量に井戸に水を入れて入れたら
ちゃんといっぱいなりますよ
いっぱいになってもあっという間に下に沈んでいっちゃうんです
意味がないんです そこで生きていきたい
死にたくないということは
井戸に水を入れるような余計な作業なんです
仏教から見れば なぜならば
どうして業がそんなことをもうやってるんだから
何年生き続けるか それは業の管轄で
それはもうやる管理しかない
自分が自分の業も知らない
だから人間なら死ぬ時は死にますよと
そこはリラックスした方がいいんです
死ぬ時は死にます それでいて力抜けて馬鹿になる
馬鹿になりません 幸福に生きてみますと
幸福に安穏に生きてみますと
テーマ変えるんです だから
俗世間と仏教の違うところは
俗世間がどうしても生きたいという気持ちで
科学 文化 あれやこれやとか作る
それで苦しみが増えるだけで
今ネットもあるし いろんなもう IC 機械いっぱいあるし
それってもう迷惑なんです
幸福に生きていきたいというふうにテーマを変えれば
素晴らしい世界が現れるんです
文化はこの道はもっと変えるんです
で 私たち一人一人が幸福に生きたいと目的変える
生きていきたいという目的は捨てる
アホらしいやと そんなのは
管理できんや そんなことはと
どうせ死ぬんだと だったらそこに踏ん張らなくてもいいでしょう
それで生きて幸福に生きたいと思ったところで
すぐ分別能力というものが必要になってくるんです
それで物事をやってはいけないこと
やってもいいこと選んでいくんです
何をすれば幸福かと選ぶ
何をすれば不幸になるかと決める
これやったら不幸になる
これやったら幸福になる
それが仏教が語る倫理と道徳の世界
よくも人間が仏教が戒律はうるさいわ
あれやるなこれやるので
私は仏教大嫌いと言っているでしょうに
世界一般的に世界で世間で一番人気ない教えは仏教なんです
だから嘘をつけばつくほど人気があるんです
人を落とし穴に落とせば落とすほど
そこは人気あるんです
落とし穴からもうちょっと上げてあげようかなと思ったら
腹が立って怒るんですね
あれは生きることを目的にしているんだからなんです
間違った生き方をしているんだからなんです
はい そういうことで また区別能力と分別能力が必要になってきて
仏道の人々は分別能力を育てていく
例えば 嘘をついてはいけないという道徳項目があるでしょ
本当はそういう道徳項目要りません
頭が悪いんだから教えたんです
だから仏教に戒律はあるのはお釈迦様のせいじゃなくて
弟子たちがアホでしたからなんです
お釈迦様は悟りを開いて
もう大体 20年間 いわゆる 50歳になるまで 55
歳 戒律はなかったみたいんです
すべてすごい頭の良かった弟子たちです
だから日本だったら 会社には会社の規則
学校には学校の規則 家の中では家の中の決まり
決まりばっかりでしょうに
手も足も出ないように
それでしっかりした管理された社会で威張るんだけど
仏教から見ればどう言えばいい？このアホらしさはもうもう呆れちゃうんです
本当は ですから この人間の知識
能力やら分別能力あったならば
ルールはないんです 安全です
ルールがあるとは 私たちには分別能力ない
だから項目を守っているんです
学校の決まりも会社の決まりも守るためになるんです
ですから この嘘をつくなよという戒律項目は本当に要りません
人が私は他の人間とどのように付き合えば幸福ですか？と考えればわかる話でしょう
あ 私はこいつを騙した方が幸福ですよと
ありえないでしょ 騙った人
騙された人に逆にやられちゃうでしょ
幸福が壊れるでしょ？不幸になるでしょ
だから幸福になりたいという目的を作ったならば
嘘をつくなよという必要もないんです
それで私は何言いたいかというと
我々はバカだからね 項目を守りますが
私も項目を守ります けど
バカだから仕方がないんです
だからもうアホでバカだから
いろんな決まり リスト書いて
これこれ守るべきとかね
教えてあげなくちゃいけない
だから戒律の歴史を読んでみるとよくわかると思いますけど
お釈迦様は組織というか
そういうのを持っていなかったんです
そこでいろんなところで弟子たちが
仏教の人々が現れて 出家したい
出家したいと言うんですね
お釈迦様だったらいいよ
それだけ終わり いいよ
終わり 組織はないんです
しかし その弟子たちが地方に行って説法して
みんな阿羅漢でしたからね
説法を聞いた人々も 私も出家したいんだと
たら この阿羅漢たちは困っちゃって
これどうすればいいかと
お釈迦様に聞いたんですね
あ まあ一応ブッダにサランガッチャ
ダンマサランガッチャ言わせて
それで十分やと それで出家する人に
じゃああんたこの三帰唱えてください
はい あんた出家ですと
これもまたまずくなっちゃって
トラブルが起きちゃって
それからじわじわじわじわと戒律やら出家儀式やら現れてくるんです
で 子供たちとかね もう出家したいのもいいやと
子供大人としてできないんだから
見習いとして置いておく
見習いだから何すればいいんだよ
何もわからないでしょ
子供たちは だったらこの 10項目を教えてあげてとか
この 10項目を守るようにと
これはサミ戒律十なんですね
そういう風にこのじわじわと組織になるんであってね
最初は組織ではなかったんですね
今は私は分別の世界喋ってるんです
あの 分別能力あれば規則は要りません
戒律も要りません この分別能力で失敗するときは
これやめなさいと言うんです
しかし 分別世界はすべて生命は幸福になるためのものなんです
それで分別の場合も行うべきことと行って
いけないことが成り立たないと
喋るべき言葉と喋ってはいけない言葉
言葉に罪がないんですよ
でも 言葉並んで選んで喋る場合は
選んでいけない組み合わせもあるし
選ばなくてはいけない組み合わせもあります
これ 文法のとこじゃないんです
例えば日本 英語で you あなたという単語には日本語でたくさん言葉があるでしょ
あなただけじゃないでしょ
辞書で私は英語辞書で you あなたがありますけど
これだけは使えませんね
だから どんな時どんな単語を選ぶのかと
決めなくちゃあかんでしょう
それ分別能力なんですね
一部の人間いるでしょ
そういう人々にとってあなたっていう言葉はあんまり使わないというね
使いますけど できるだけ例えば議員さんとかね
お医者さんとかね 呼ぶ場合は
あのね あんたとは言わないでしょ
あのね 先生と言うんですね
だから そういうふうに言葉にしたっても道徳がありまして
それを仏教ではね もう 4種に分けて戒律項目として教えてはいるんですね
はい まあしゃべりすぎですね
こういうテーマで はい
これで世界は違いということにまた戻ってみましょう
この正しい知識っていうのは何なのかと
間違っている知識って何なのかと
知識とは区別能力 その勉強していると
私が勉強する場合はすべて知識が間違っているんです
だから世の中の知識は
役に立っていると同時に危険でしょ
どんな知識も役に立っていると同時に危険なんです
どんな知識も人を助けるためにも
人を殺すためにも使える
例えば文章を書く 言葉
いとも簡単にそれで人を殺せますよ
言葉は美しいじゃないんです
うかつに言論の自由を言うんじゃないんです
本当は言論の自由あってはならないんです
というか 初めから言論の自由は存在しないんです
みんなわかってないだけで
言葉には分別能力が必要です
いわゆる道徳倫理なし
道徳倫理ない人には言葉を使う権利がないんです
道徳倫理ない人が言葉を使うなら
言葉の能力があります
ものすごい情熱で ものすごく達筆で書ける
小説を書いただけでも
読んだ人が人殺しに行けるようにすることはできます
小説を読んで読んで なんか変な気分になっちゃって
出て行って人を殺しちゃったと
狙い定めて殺すこともできますよ
誰もやってないんだけどね
中国でカルチャーレボリューションという時代で出てたけど
文化革命ね 文化大革命という時はいつでもみんなマオツェドンのをね
本を読みながら破壊に行く
だからマオツェドンがね
すごい頭のいい人で ものすごい文章を書ける人間で
それには問題ないんです
それで巧みに書く 巧みというんですかね
これ若者たちがそれを読んで読んで自分の国を破壊に行くんですね
知識人潰しましょうとかね
偉そうにカルチャーリボリューションという言葉まで使った人
だから間違った単語でしょ
カルチャーっていうのは毎日育てることであって
リボリューションというのは逆にすることじゃないんです
だからリボリューションという言葉の使い方は間違ってます
で リっていうのはバックという意味もありますよ
止まりなくという意味もあります
だからリピートする時のリとリターンの時のリは意味が違うんです
でしょ リピート 繰り返せなさい
リターン 戻しなさいなんです
だからREには意味 2つ
正反対に 2つあるんです
そんなことも知らず 革命
日本語でどんな漢字かわかりませんだけど
革命書いた  革命ってどんな意味ですかね
革命っていう場合は王朝が変わることです
なるほど  命って命ですけどね
要するに 天命が皇帝に下って
その王朝が変わる  うん
英語ではそんな意味はないんですからね
だからリボルビングリボリューションっていうのは
終わりなく回転するというものなんですね
これ 後ろに回転させるっていう意味っていうのは
それは違うんですね ま
とにかく彼らがやったことは何かというと
せっかく人間築いてきた文化を壊して壊して壊して交代するんでしょ
これ間違いと分かって
今はもう西洋よりも西洋的なやり方でやっているんですね
それもやり過ぎ まあ中国人何でやったってもね
徹底的にやるんだから仕方がないんですね
だから今はもう徹底的にやる
これ 徹底的にやるところは
仏教はちょっと待ってくださいと
ある程度で制御しなさいとは言いたいんだけど
聞いてくれません  私はポイントに出したかったのは
この言葉というのは 文化であって
そちらにも分別能力が必要です
言語を学んだんだからといって喋る権利はないんです
文章を書けるんだからで
書く権利はないんです
どこで権利を獲得するかというと
分別能力からなんです
分別能力ある人は書いてほしいんです
あの これはあの 差別 分別
区別という単語 三語三つありますけど
これは英語の世界では難しいんです
成り立たないんです 単語ないんです
これは大乗仏教の単語で
今ずっと説明してますけど
英語では全部同じ言葉を使うんです
ものは違う場合はディファレンスという言葉を使いますね
で 差別する場合はdiscriminateという言葉はダメと
しかし 分別の場合もdiscriminateという言葉を使うんですね
だから英語のdiscriminateという言葉は意味二つ持っているんです
差別することと 明確に分別して良いものを選ぶこと
だからちょっと面倒くさいんです
よかったね 英語できなくて
私だけ苦労しているんですね
単語を探そうとして discriminate
というね だから時々ね
もうdiscrimination反対とえらいことやってますよ
あれは差別反対という意味でね
でもdiscriminationなければ頭が働きませんよ
そこでヴィパッサナー瞑想を説明するときでも
あれはdiscriminate knowledgeと訳するんです
言葉ないんです 日本語ではそういう 3つの単語がありますから
皆様にだけはあまり混乱しないで理解できると思います
そこで次に私は入れたいポイントは
知識は役にもなる 毒にもなる
このところはどこから現れるのかと
包丁は凶器にもなる 道具にもなる
この差はどこにあるんですかね
まあ鉄砲は道具になりませんよ
あれはもう人を殺すために作ったものだからね
それは知識は間違って使っているんです
でもしかし 包丁は 包丁は文化の中で必要なもの
生きることは便利に楽にしてくれるものなんです
しかし それも凶器にもなる
マッチは？役に立つ 立ちますよ
でもこれが えらい怖いものにもなる
マッチ 1本で家一軒燃やすこともできます
これ どこでこの差が生まれるんですか？答え簡単
もう時間もないんだからさっさと言います
自我なんです 私なんです
で それ入っちゃうと 知識はねつ造するんです
私の気持ちに知識を変えようとするんです
テクノロジー変えようとするんです
技術を変えようとするんです
例えば腹が立ちました
自我がなければ腹が立たないでしょ
自分がマッチは持っている
そこで持っている他の知識も組み合わせて
ガソリンは買えませんだから灯油買ったりいろいろして組み合わせて
マッチ1本で家一軒を放火する
それで家一軒じゃなくて
並べている家は全部燃えてしまう
だからその人は家を放火するためには知識を使ったんです
区別能力を使ったんです
しかし この知識はとんでもない危険なものになったんです
どこで？自我で そこで学校で気持ちよく勉強できる人も
勉強できない子もいる
勉強してもしても知識が育たない人もいるし
軽々と知識が広がって育てる人もいる
このスイッチはどこにあるんですか？自我にあるんです
自我が割り込むと なかなか先へ進まないんです
数学を学ぶ子も 自我を入れちゃうと
足し算 引き算で十分やと思っちゃうんです
もっと自我が割り込むと
それは要らんやと 電卓あるんだから
と 自我がない子は あれ
あれ これって面白いと
足し算があって どんどんできて
引き算があって どんどんできて
割りあってそれできて
かけ算ものすごくできちゃって
それ割り掛けだけじゃなくて
さらに方法あるんだよとかね
面白い 面白いと その子は
これは己の役に立つか立たないか
俺がやりたい やりたくないかだけなく
すべて捨てて差を探してはいく
差を見つかるたびに面白くなる
三角形 長方形 あれやこれ八角形とかね
そこを勉強して面白くなったところで
もう三次元のものを勉強する羽目になる
ああ 前とは違うことをやらなくちゃとかね
体積勉強しなくちゃあかんやとかね
もっとあるんだとかね
それからそちらにも入らない数学あるんですね
だってこの地球のね 公転でもいい加減でしょ
正しい輪っかで走ってないでしょ
本当にいい加減だからね
月にしたっても 丁寧に太陽回っていないんですよ
もう だからちゃんと輪っかで走るんだったら
私にも計算できますよ
あの動きの じゃなくて
みんなあれ 何て言いますか
ちょっとブラン大円で走ってるんですね
めんどくさいね あれ 計算するのは
でもやる人ちゃんとやってますよ
月食 月食 何時何秒で来るかちゃんと言ってくれますよ
だからそういう人々は
俺がやりたい 俺がやりたくない気持ちあったらやる
そんなのはやらないんです
だから自我を張ろうとすると勉強できなくなるんです
自我が張る人は勉強したっても
社会の不幸のためにそれを使うんです
だから世の中で知識人なのに嫌な人がいて
知識人だから愛される人もいる
ポイント簡単 自我張るかないかなんです
経済学者がいる この経済学者がただ儲かるために株の世界分析ばっかりしちゃうと
あんまり誰も相手にしないんです
この経済学が自分のことを置いておいて
人類のことを考えちゃうと
すごい褒め称えてくれるんです
素晴らしい経済学者やと
株の売買 マーケットの変動ばっかり研究する人々は暗くて
あんまり社会には社会には好かれませんね
有名人にもならない その人々はお金なんぼ儲かるかことしか考えてない
弁護士は自分が弁解してお金なんぼ儲かるかだけ考える
弁護士は嫌われる 非難を受ける
では 法律知識は使っていかに楽に我々生き生きてもらうかなというふうな自我を捨ててしゃべる人々は
法律家として世界で褒められる
称えられる 能力も拡大する
だから勉強したければ
知識を拡大していければ
たった一つだけ捨てるんです
自我を捨てるんです 自我を割り込んだら
知識はものすごく捏造してしまっちゃって
客観的な知識にならないんです
会計の勉強をしたら 自我のある人はいかにごまかすかと
学ぶんです プログラミングを学んだ人々は
どうやって人のシステムをハッキングして壊すのかと
それしか頭がないんです
人のシステムに違法アクセスする方法
能力は同じなんです プログラマーと
大したことない 本当に単純なコードリストがあってね
それは覚えるだけなんですけど
あれって変なコードですけど
簡単に覚えられるんです
いや 私はできませんから
聞かないでください 昔ちょっとやってみたんだ
あ なんだ 単純だと思った時はあるんです
説法しなくちゃかんだから
これできなかったんですね
ですから このコードパターンちゃんと勉強するって
これ難しくはないんだけど
一人がエンジニアで 一人がハッカーで
一人が高い給料をもらって
一人が刑務所に行くと
自我ですよ プログラマーは会社の役に立つこと
人の役に立つことを考えているんですね
自我のある人が暗くて
どうやってあのシステムを壊すのかどうかね
壊しても何も自分には利益も何もないんです
でもアクセスして壊す
ウイルス作って送る で
我々のシステムにウイルスを送ったんだからといって
もう私から 1円ももらわないでしょうに
あるいは私のシステムをまた直してもらっても
別の人にお金払ってるんだからね
ウイルス送った人には払ってないんです
だからもうアホめところでしょうに
そこでこういうわかりやすく言おうと作ったんだけど
もっと難しいんで このポイントは
自分で物事に良し悪し判断するんです
例えば あの人なら美しい
この人なら醜いとどうやって言える？その人が区別能力を持ってます
区別能力では美しいと醜いと成り立たないんです
この人はまあ 170センチ背が高い
この人は 173 そんな程度なんです
この人の肌の色はこの色
医学的に見ても この人はこの DNA を持っている
この人はこの DNA を持っている
そちらで美しい醜いはないんです
例えば この人の場合 皮膚にはすごい問題がある
言葉おかしいんだけど
皮膚が荒れたり いろいろもう大変赤くなったり
痒くなったり もういろいろ液体みたいなのが出るでしょ
体から出たりとかね まあ一般的に言えば病気ですね
皮膚の激しい で 遺伝子的に見れば
この人の遺伝子の場合はこういう風になっている
この人の遺伝子の場合はこういう風にならない
直してくださいと言ったら
まあできることはやりますけどね
そこであなたは皮膚病で気持ち悪い
あなたの皮膚が美しくてなんて可愛いということはアホ以外は言わないはずなんです
でも言ってるでしょ あれが自我なんです
それでデータが頭の中で自動的に捏造されます
例えば医者のところにお腹が壊して二人が患者さんが来る
一人がまあ 10 歳ぐらいの子供
一人が 80 歳のおじいさんかおばあさん
この医者には医学的な知識があるんだけど
かわいいと気持ち悪いという自我を持っている
そうすると子供の場合は
あーかわいい かわいいんだい
そんな大したことない
君は元気だからすぐ治りますよ
薬あげますからとか すごい丁寧に治療する
ボロボロ年取ってくる
おばあちゃんかおじいさんからまあ年寄りって面倒くさい
なんだあなたの病気はと
ちょっとお腹が あ そうですか
じゃあこの薬調べもしないで
やる可能性ある だからそこはものすごく人間の世界で
そうやってある人を特別扱い
日本語の言葉あるでしょ？美人はなんとかありますね
何でしたっけ あれは なんかありますよ
美人が医者でもどこでも儲かるかなんとかとかね
まあだからいろいろ美人パスってね
結構物事も聞くでしょ
ことわざを思い出せませんだけどね
ことわざではなくて 日常使うフレーズなんですけどね
それであまりにもバカバカしくてバカバカらしくて面白いんだから
私も時々使いますよ まああんた美人だからこれはちょっと許してあげるとかね
それは私はそうだからではなくて
言葉が面白いんだから
バカバカらしいんだけど
使ってるだけなんです
人が間違いを犯したら許してあげるのは常識なことで
まあちょっと冗談とりましょうと
まああなたは美人だから仕方がないね
じゃあ許してあげると
もし相手がやっぱり美人だから許すとか思ったら
それは勘違い でも世の中はそうじゃないんですね
美人はなんとなく特別扱いされる
能力なくても上に行っちゃう
この選挙なんかではね
美人美男が結構投票を取りますよ
よく自分の命預かるんだから
あんなバカな態度で 自分の国では
前の悪徳政治家がやっていた時は
芸能人というのはいとも簡単に政治家になるんですね
あるテレビでもある女の女優さんなんですけど
もう質問しちゃって もうもう右も左もわからないアホな女なんです
それで憲法のこういう条文について今改良しようと思ってるので
あんた憲法って何でわからないんです？それで怒って
彼女の応援する連中もテレビに攻撃で
何それ？質問するならば前もって質問出さなくちゃあかんではないかと
それだったら準備してくるで
あのね そんなことできません
これは現場で質問しますって言ってもう番組が中止になっちゃったんだけど
これ選挙で勝つんだから
美人で 今度も今選挙あるんだけど
芸能人が全部リストカットしたんです
ですから この自分の国でも起こること
日本でもタレントさんはやがて政治家に入り込んできますね
まあ日本人がちゃんと知識勉強しているんだから
まんざら悪いことをするわけではないんだけど
大したこともしないんですね
東京の縮み待ったからね
ですから まあそこで我々の自我が入っているんです
好みが入っているんです
そこで勝手にねつ造して判断する
それは正しい知識ではないんです
例えば政治家といえば
もうどんな選挙区で どんな地方か国かとかね
管理する人なんですね
それであなたに能力あるのか
マネジメント力があるのかと
これぐらい はい あなたはどうですかと
それであなたは何やりたいのかと
ああ そうか 悪くない 能力はと調べて
あなたは何になりたいかと
やれる 実行できる能力
そこで投票する人は決めればいいでしょう
民主主義の世界で誰一人もそういうふうに決めて投票してないんです
誰一人やった 政治家の能力を調べて
実行できるかないか調べてやってないでしょ
誰一人もやってないと思いますよ
だから区別能力を感情を入れちゃって
間違ったというか 間違いではなくて
ねつ造する結果に出す
そういうのは差別世界に入るんです
そこで生命に生まれつき感情があるんです
だから輪廻転生するんです
生きていきたい 死にたくないとかね
楽しみたいとかね 幸福になりたいはないんです
楽しみたい そういう感情あるんだから
それに煩悩というんですね
それで感情では生きていられません
生きていきたい気持ちだけ一人歩きさせちゃうと
直ちに殺されます 楽しみたい気持ちだけ生かしちゃうと直ちに死んでしまいます
だから 感情と一緒に業が区別能力をインストールして命を作るんです
そこでこの生命が感情をもとにして区別能力を育てるんです
儲かるために学ぶ 人殺すために学ぶ
敵に勝つために学ぶ 世界一になるために学ぶとかね
社会で自分の立場を築くために学ぶとかね
そうやって感情で学ぶんです
だから誰だって自分の知識
能力 拡大していないんですよ
この自我が入るとある程度で終わっちゃうんです
だからなんで犬に ２ たす ２ も ２ かける ２ 分からないかというと
その感情があって 能力があって
それでリミットされているんですね
だから犬は生きられる程度で時間どうなったってありますか
あと 1時間ぐらい  休憩取った方がいいかどうか分からないね
で 生きられる いわゆる生きていきたい
死にたくない その程度にロックされているんです
犬の能力は 学ぶ能力は
そこで人間にはもうロックあるんだけど
本当は鍵かけてないんです
知識には ロックはあります
ロックかけてないんです
そこで生まれる時は 一応安全のためにロックをかけて生まれてきます
しかし いつだってこれカチッと開けられる
面白いことは 人間がこの知識にあるロックの鍵を開けてないんです
それで みんな自分が生きるために
自分のライバルに勝つために
長生きするために たくさん儲かるために学びまくるんです
研究しまくるんです 犬の次元は進んでないんです
だから人間にはいくら頑張っても知り得ないものはいっぱいあるんです
例えば ここまで科学が進んでいるのに
命のテーマ定義できません
心の存在をに証明を出すことは不可能
鍵かけられているんです
これほど明確なのに 人間の次元を超えることはあり得ないんです
科学世界では 人間は人間で閉じ込めることしか研究しないんです
だから犬だって同じことでしょうに
犬は犬で生きるために必要なものしか学べないんです
この鍵 でかけて生まれるんだけど
人間になったら開けられます
ユーキャンオープンイット
なんだ 開けて開けて開けることはできるんです
犬はできません 餓鬼道に落ちて幽霊になったら開けられません
だから解脱可能な次元があるんです
天国に生まれたら誰だって解脱する
それはできません もう天界でももうできる世界できない世界あるんです
天界で悟りに達する人々は
ここで人間として鍵を開けた人々なんです
はい それをそういうわけで
我々は感情を持っていて
感情で生きていきたい
死にたくないだけの気持ちで知識拡大していく
区別能力は拡大している
それによく助かるのは
物事は違うんだから 勉強はできるんだけど
せいぜいほんのちょっとのことを勉強して人生終わります
しかし 自我を捨てて幸福になりたいと勉強していくと
いくらでも勉強できるようになります
もう拡大するわするわ
知る範囲はきりがなく拡大するんです
で なんで世の中違い それは面白い
でも我々にとっては違うことは困るということになっているんです
それは自我があるんだからなんです
自分で世の中のことを管理しようとしているんだからなんです
要するに法則を犯しているんです
法則は犯せないんです
犯せない法則を犯すをする人は
判決を受けるんです やられます
不幸になります それで
世の中に美しい人間 醜い人間は存在しないんです
可愛い猫と可愛くない猫は存在しないんです
で 私たちはあなたはあまり気持ち悪いとかね
人を差別する場合は 私たちはこの違いは自我で受け取って苦しんでいるんです
というわけで 自我で違いを見ると
見るたびに気持ち悪くなるんです
例えば 私に自我があって
このマイクロフォンはちょっと形が古くて
デザインももう初期時代のデザインでしょう
初期でもないんだけどね
もっと新しいデザインのね
いいマイク買った方がいいんじゃないかなと自分で決めたら苦しいでしょう
見るたびに こちらにある花がもうちょっと違う色だった方が良かったのにとかね
思ったら この花見るたびに私は苦しいでしょう
ただ 私の勝手で この花は名前を持ってないんか
名前を私が知らないか
どちらかですけどね どちらですかね
名前は持ってないかな
もともと持ってないんですよ
皆さんが勝手に名前をつけてるんだからね
私は知りませんだけど
例えば 私はこの花ではなくて
この花嫌い バラやらユリやら
そういう花が好きにしましょう
そうすると 嫌い花がこちらで置いておくとどうなる？私は
見るたびにひどい目に遭わなくちゃいけないでしょ
だから 私の自我のせいで
違いが苦しみに 地獄に変わってくるんです
私に自我がなかったら
違うことが楽しくて面白くて仕方かなくなっちゃうんです
例えば この舞台の上にちょびっとゴミがあるとしましょう
イライラしますね なんで舞台の上にゴミがあるだけでイライラするんですかね
自分の判断があるんですね
見るものは綺麗にしなくちゃあかんやと
これは変でしょ？綺麗って何？清潔って何？皆様できると思う
この舞台の床はね すごい綺麗に清潔にすることは不可能です
いくら磨いても汚いんです
汚いと言うならば そこでちょびっと紙
潰した紙一つあったら
舞台の前にゴミだって
これおかしい それで私は意図的にそれは置いておいてください
言っちゃうと これやった方がよかったね
公演始まる前に ちょっと紙くず潰しちゃってね
真ん中に置いておいて
そうすると皆様方 公演終わるまで気持ち悪くて
イライラしちゃって 自分で立ち上がって
これゴミ箱に入れたくなったりして
結局苦しみだと思いますよ
そういうことで違い見る
違い見て自分のエゴを出す
それからはい 苦しんでくださいと
オープンライセンス いくらでも苦しめます
だから世の中ってそんなもんやと思っちゃえば
そこは自分にも当てはめなくちゃあかんです
自分見てください 違うものだらけでしょ
爪見たら同じじゃないでしょ
5種類ですから それも左は 5種類
右 5種類 これ似てないんですね 10
種類なんですね これ女性の方々苦労してるでしょ？ネイルアーティストのところに行って
全部同じく見せてやるそうと
うまくいかないんだから
人工的に貼るんですね
はい なんか変なものを貼ってもらうんです
そこまでお金かかる羽目になったのは何ですかね
ですから 目は違う 右目と左目は違う
右目でものを見て脳に入るデータと
左目でものを見て脳脳に入るデータがそれぞれ違う
そこで脳がそれを組み合わせて一つに画像にする
で 訓練できれば 左目で見える世界
右目で見える世界をやった方がいいと思いますよ
もしやってみたんですけどね
まあいたって簡単なできてますけどね
やっぱり別々に違うものが見えるんですね
右目が見えることと左目見える
それぞれ違い それで両方やっちゃうと両方バラバラに見えちゃうんだから困るんだけど
で どちらにしようかな
それでやっぱりこれを合成して合体させなくちゃいけない
また合体して置くんですね
音も同じなんです 右に聞こえる
左に聞こえる音もね 同じもの聞こえません
だからそうやって細胞も一個一個違う
それで体の中で違う細胞たちがうまく頑張ってくれてるでしょうに
もし心臓細胞が血管細胞に向かってお前ら気持ち悪い
わし心臓細胞がすごいしっかりできてるんだと
なんだこのニョロニョロ血管細胞ですかとけなしたりするとどうなる？すぐ死んじゃいます
だって心臓の中に血管が流れてるんだからね
皮膚の細胞が皮膚の下にある筋肉の細胞を馬鹿にして侮辱する羽目になったらどうなる？死んじゃうでしょうに
だから細胞一個一個差があったからこそ
この命でしょ それで何が見えるかというと
自我張るなよと 違いを認めましょうと
違いを認めて お互い共和共存
調和ネットワーク 違いが必須です
例えば大根の味と 塩の味がまるっきり同じだったら
大根煮る時は塩を入れる
大根の味と えーと 何でしたっけ？醤油の味はまるっきり同じ
違いはありません そうすると大根を煮る時は醤油を入れる
だから塩は塩で独立している
砂糖は砂糖で独立している
誰とも似てないんです
醤油は醤油で自分が独立している
大根は大根で俺は違いますよと
みんなと独立しているんです
そこで美味しい大根煮が出来上がるでしょ
みんな何やってるのかと我々呆れている上で違いがあって世界が成り立っているんです
演奏できる人がいるんだから
我々は音楽を楽しむんです
全ての人類に演奏できるならば
世界から音楽消えます
だって面白くないんですからね
どんな人間にも歌える能力あるならば
歌う 歌い 歌が世界から消えます
あれ 商売になりません
美しく鳴く鳥たちがいるでしょ
1円ももらってないね
だってその種類の鳥たちは誰にだって鳴きますからね
人間の場合は歌える人は金もらっちゃいます
なぜ他の人に歌えないんだからなんです
だからものが違いでなければ大変なことになります
では 仏教の論理に入ってさっさと終了します
仏教はすべて無常ということを教えているんですね
一個一個瞬間で現れて瞬間で消えるということは一個一個違うんです
あの仏教ではこの戻すという言葉はないんです
先に回転するリボリューションなんです
リボリューションであって
これはデベロップメントではないんです
プログレスではないんです
プログレスって辞書をひき見れば
先に進むという意味なんですけど
でも意味としては発展するという意味も入っています
ただリボル回転していく
私たちは一個の細胞で生まれたんです
それからその細胞はどこに行ったかわかりません
それから新たな新たな細胞が生まれて
古い細胞死んで 死んで死んで
今も細胞が死んで新たな細胞が生まれていくんです
だからひとコマも同じコマがないんです
人生の中で 同じ人に二度と会えないんです
同じ食べ物を二回食べられません
一切は一回きりです しかし
回転していくんです 変化して変化していく
止まりません そこで何が違ですかと
何に何に執着するのかと
一回きりだから 全て もう二度と会えませんよと
執着する あなた良い あなた悪い
判断できる そういうことで
違いを知るとは無常を知ること
最終的に無常を知っちゃうとどうなるかというと
あの分別も要らなくなっちゃうんです
もう成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
区別も成り立たないんです
もう何にも成り立たない
だったらその心は何なのかと
いう 何なのかで言う言葉もないんです
それに解脱というんです
涅槃というんです これがいい
これが悪いと言えないんですよ
瞬間のことだからね これがいいと
これが悪いと判断するために
私がいなくちゃあかんでしょ
次の瞬間で別な私ですからね
だから A さんがいいというものに B さんが乗らなくちゃいけないんですね
困ります それで A さんがいいと思うのは A さんの勝手でしょうに
それで私は A さんでいて
リンゴがおいしいと決めちゃって
それからリンゴ買ってきて食べるんですね
その時は C さんになってるんですね
C さんにとってはリンゴまずくなっているんです
苦労しなくちゃいけないんですね
その時は そこで無常を知っちゃうと
心が私たちのように働くことをしないんです
瞬間瞬間認識はするんだけど
それはすべてパス だから差別は当然ない
区別もない 分別もない
全部乗り越えている 一生でもその国でいられませんだから当然お釈迦様も区別世界に戻ります
お釈迦様には分別世界は要りません
もう悪いことしませんだから
しかし お釈迦様の知識能力っていうのは
どうやって知ってるかとわからないんです
例えば宇宙が無限にあることやら
太陽系がたくさんあることやら
宇宙はね ものすごい気が狂う
時間経った後もう壊れていくことやら
よく見るんですよ 虫眼鏡さえも道具を持ってなかったんですよ
私は草履を履いても お釈迦様草履さえも履かなかったんです
道具ゼロ なんでここまで知れるのか
知れられるのかと 自我がないんだからなんです
客観的に学んだんだからなんです
だから皆様も心を主観から客観に入れ替えると
いくらでも知識世界が広がっていくんです
はい 最後のポイント 我々には区別能力をインストールして生まれてくる
そこで過去生命にインストールされている区別能力は違います
同じじゃないんです 人間であっても
みんな人間好きわけじゃないんです
人間だからって みんな肉好きわけじゃないんです
人間だから食べられるものはほんのわずかなんです
鶏とか豚とか牛とか卵とか
いくつかの野菜とかね
米とかね 麦とかね 食べるものってほんのわずかです
クマさんはもっと食べます
だから我々は選ぶんだけど
だからニンジン好きな人はいる
たくさんいるかも チキン好きな人はたくさんいるかもしれませんだけど
みんな同じものを好きじゃわけじゃないんです
なぜならば これ 業がこの区別能力は自分のバージョンをインストールしているんです
この私はマイバージョンの区別能力を持って
皆様も自分のバージョンの区別能力を持ってるんです
ということは すべての生命は互い違います
似ている生命は人間だけじゃない
存在しないんです そこで皆様方ね
あのタンクでメダカを飼う
同じく見えるでしょう
でもメダカは一匹一匹違う生命なんです
この先の研究するとすごい困りますね
だって見て同じに見えるんだからね
そこで苦労して 尾っぽの微妙な差で
あ これは何々こと名前付けちゃうんです
ヒレのね あのドーサルフィンと言いますけど
日本語では分かりません
背中にある あれで今日は講演作らなかったんだけど
日本語の単語 単語調べなかったんです
まあとにかく これだけ覚えてください
アリは皆同じじゃないんです
同じ種類のアリであっても
一匹一匹違う生命なんです
私たちにそこまでわからないんだからといってね
アリ一匹ちゃんしっかりした生命なんです
そこで人間が もし差別するならば
こんなに危険な罪あると思いますか？どんな立場で差別しますかね
私はモデルにするでしょう
自分をモデルにして差別していくんです
自我を ですから 修行しても立ち難い煩悩がこの自我なんです
罪の中でも恐ろしい罪を起こす行為なんです
ですから 我々はアリ一匹でも互い違います
この違うことを探し 楽しもうと
子供が子供を見て楽しいなのは
みるみるうちに変なことをやるからなんです
みるみるうちに変なことやっちゃうんです
毎日成長するんです  1週間前の子供と今日見ると違うんですね
だから変化すること 激しいんだから楽しいんですよ
子供の場合は楽しいと思うのは愛着あるからですね
愛着を捨てちゃえば 世界すべて楽しいんです
世界すべて面白いんです
そこで無常に達したら
何にも執着しないで 区別
分別 差別 すべて乗り越えて
究極の安穏状態を作ることはできます
話は終わりです  よろしくお願いします
はい 無常っていうのは大切だっていうのはわかってるんですけど
この自分の立ち位置っていうのをどこで見ればいいのかっていうと
ちょっと教えていただきたいんですけど
無常っていうと もう自分自身の意識
意識とか意見とか そういうものがなくなってしまうと
自分自体がどこにあるのかっていう
だからないんで もともと
だからあると思って困ってるんです
だからその場面 その場面だけなんです
我々自分探ってますけど
今そちらに座ってるでしょ
今の自分とホールに入った時の自分違うでしょ
講演終わったとたん 立った途端違う自分でしょ
駅に行ったらまた違う自分でしょ
家に戻ったらまた違うでしょ
だからないんです 結局は
それが面白いんです なぜかというと
その場面 その場面で対応すればいいんです
それですごく精神的に楽になって
どんな変化にも対応できるんです
自分がいると変化に対応できないんです
そこで会社の問題にどう喋れば喋ろうかなと
家で宿題やったってもうまくいかないんですよ
データそろったり 順番に並べたりすることは客観的なこと
それは必要ですけど やっぱりその雰囲気でどんな演技するのかっていうことは
その場で決まるんですよ
ですから すべて無常だから
だから自我がないんですね
自分というものは それは一時的なもので
ずっと変化するんですね
映画があるのかといえば
あると言いたければ言っちゃえなんですね
本当は画像のコマの流れなんですね
静止画像の 今デジタルだからね
それでもあの その場合は静止画像さえもないんです
しかし あるデータの種類でカットして
あるデータでカットして
スクリーンで線で絵を描いていくんですよ
早いんだからわからない
目にはね たまたまデジタル映画を見ると
この下に見えますね あのノイズラインは
あの画素を変えたところは
まあとにかく そんな昔のあのあれ
フィルムといいますね
そこだったら絵がないでしょ？動画がないでしょ
静止画 1個  1個  1個  1個
自分もそんなもんなんですね
だからまとめて自分と言ってるから
だから困るんですよ それで
だから自分自身が瞬間瞬間変わっていくんだと覚えておけば
あ これちょっとやばいと
いつでも気をつけて その場面で自分の役柄を果たさなくちゃあかんやと思うんですね
失敗したらまた直せませんだからね
一回きりだからね ですから
自我私が自分ないということがわかればわかるほど
その人々はものすごく楽に失敗しないで生きていられます
はい 以上です  えっと 他に
あ すみません ちょっとそっちにいると字が斜めんでマイクを回していただいて
えっと 最終的に差別 区別
分別を乗り越えるということなんですけども
分別って道徳世界っていうものは
その無常を知る上で役に立つというか
そのステップとして必要なことなんでしょうか
そうなんですね 必要なんですね
だからこの すべて法則だから
例えば土の塊があります
そちらに金粉も入ってます
10グラムぐらい 土は 1トンぐらいある
そこでこの 10グラム金取ってと言ったら取れる？取れないんですね
そこでまずどうしましょうか
次どうしましょうかとかね
あらゆる私がやり方はわかりませんだけど
土を洗って洗って 最終的に金が入ってる
こう なんとかね 鉱物まで持ってきて
それでも金にならない
それからまた化学変化させて
いろんなことをして やっと
10グラムの金を取り上げますね
そうやってすべて無常であるんだけど
どんなものにもプログラムというのを成り立つのですね
すべて無常です 籾一個だったら無常です
これ プログラムで動かしちゃうと
籾を植えて稲にして 稲を育てて
それでたくさん籾が出て
そこから籾殻を取って
ちゃんと茹でてご飯になるとかね
籾一個でお腹いっぱい美味しいご飯食べるぞっていうことはありえないんですね
そういうわけで もう因果法則ですよ
すべて因果法則っていうのは
ある鍛錬に丁寧にプログラムで物事は変化する
これも言いたいと書いておいたんだけど
忘れちゃった あの物事は変化します
無常ですけど パターンがあるんだと
パターンっていうのは因果法則ですね
ですから 私はこんなもんで
いくらか区別の能力を持って生まれて
自我があるんだから 区別の能力を差別しちゃってひどい目に遭った
なのに生きていきたいと思っている
生きていきたいことは
ちょっと区別能力を使っちゃうといらん努力なんですね
生きていきたい 死にたくないのは
あんなのはいらん 考える必要はないんです
だからそれは置いておいて
幸福になりたいという新たな課題を意図的に作る
そこは新たな課題 意図的に作っちゃったところで
新たな宿題が現れてくる
そこで分別という世界が現れてくるんです
だから生きていきたいだけ
死にたくないだけ思っている人には人殺すことできますよ
人を殺しに行っちゃえばいいんだから
俺は金が欲しい 生きていきたい
この人は金持ってるようで金くれと言ってもくれません
脅したっても気にもしない
だったら殺しちゃう 殺して金盗んじゃう
だから生きていきたい気持ちがあったらそれできる
しかし 幸福になりたいだったらこれできません
それはできないんですね
そこで私には金がないんですけど
私は幸福に生きていきたい
ですから 人は金を持っていてもね
これは私のものじゃないんだから
ここで我慢する あるいはどうしたっても
お腹が空いているんだったら
本当は実はお腹が空いてますけど
何か私はおかわり代わりに何かしてあげますから
ちょっと弁当一つ買っていただけませんか？と頼むことでもする
それでもしかすると その人は喜んで
大変あなたはとかね 弁当買ってあげて
なんであなたに仕事ないのか
なんで金がないのかとか話し合って仲良くもなって
別にその人から仕事をもらわなくたっても
幸福な雰囲気が現れたでしょ
そういうわけで 幸福になるプログラムを作ったら
分別ということは成り立つ
これで分別っていうのは道徳で倫理で
最終的に究極な幸福になるというところまで持っていっちゃうんですね
そこで仏道では幸福になって
なって なって なって なって
なって なってなっていって
究極の頂点になる そちらには分別も何もありません
涅槃という境地になるんです
だからこれははしごなんですね
登るための お釈迦様はイカダという言葉を使っているんですね
渡るための で すごい危険なところから登って登って
安全なところに行ったら
まあはしごはいらない
ものすごい危険な川のたとえといえばいい
はしごよりはね 恐ろしいところで住んでいて
殺されるわ 苦しいわ 恐ろしい川がありまして
これは感情のことで とにかくイカダを作って渡る
渡ったら川も関係いらない
恐ろしい川 イカダもいらない
もう使っちゃったんだから
涅槃という境地に入る
ですから そこですべて捨てるということで
涅槃に達した人は 分別も区別も区別は残りますけど
まあ差別は毛頭ないし
分別も乗り越える はい
必要です とにかく  はい
他に あ じゃあ マイクを回していただけますか？ あ
質問させていただきます
先ほどのお話を聞きまして
自我という単語と単が出てきたんですけれども
自我といわゆる個性というもののですね
2つあると思うんですけども
自我と個性は私の中ではちょっと似てるような感じがするんですけども
同じではないというのは気づいているんですが
自我と個性の違いを簡単に教えていただきたいと思います
はい これ簡単です 自我っていうのは
この生きるファンクションのね
見る 聞く 感じる 悲しくなる
楽しくなる 疲れる 寝るとかね
そういうファンクションに
心と肉体のファンクションにぴったし一つラベルを貼っておく
私と 私ってどちらにあなたラベル貼ったかというとわからない
仏教はあなた肉体感覚見る
それにラベル貼ったでしょと教えてあげる
人間がこの肉体ではなく
自我がある この心ではなく
別に自分がいると思っているんです
これはものすごい誤解なんです
それは邪見という 仏教の人々もやっぱり自分がいるでしょうと言うんです
あのね あなた この肉体と感覚と見たものと聞いたものにまとめてちょっとラベルを貼ってるだけやと
あ そうか じゃあ見てくださいと
ずっと見るものは変わっていくでしょうにと
すーっと聞くものは変わっていくでしょう
ずっと感覚は変わっていくでしょうと
だから流れる川をなんか手で捕まって捕まった
捕まったと言っているような感じなんですね
捕まってないんですね
流れてるんですね でもなんか捕まったような気分になりますね
例えば蛇口から水を流しましょう
流しちゃ じゃあこの水を捕まってやるぞと
ずっと そうするとちっと縮るんではなくて
ちょっと穴を塞ぐと そうすると捕まったような捕まっているような気分になりますね
でも捕まってないんです
流れてるんで そういうことで
その程度は仏教では自分という自我ではなくてね
己 なんとかラベルが必要だからね
これが本当にいると思ってはいけません
それは自我が錯覚ですね
個性は個性ですよ もう違うんだからね
すべて一回きりだからね
そこで私の個性はこちらに来た時と今違うんです
もう変わっているんです
講演が終わったらまた個性が変わるんです
例えばみんなとも一緒に帰るでしょ
私はこの顔しない その時はその話もしない
別人です そんなもんで
個性はそんなもんなんですね
それで我々困るのは スマナサーラが例えば帰るところ
あすこさんと一緒に帰りますけど
別人になるんだけど あすこさんと同じ人間にはなりませんね
変わった人間になったんです
そう それがスマナサーラでしょう
という感じにはあるんですね
そういうことは この流れには何かパターンがあるんですね
例えば上から水を落としちゃうとちゃんとうちに落ちますよ
でも 蛇口から水を下ろすことと
口が同じなね やかんから水を下ろすと何か違うんでしょ
それからホースはホースからまた違うんですね
そのように私が瞬間瞬間変化するんだけど
この変化をじーっと見ると
あるパターンがあるんですね
それは変えられない 変えたまあ取ったことないんだけどね
例えば私も年取りますよ
皆様と同じく 年取ってはいくんだけど
この肉体の年取り方と他の人の年取り方が違うんです
そこで皆様も仏教を勉強しているし
私も仏教を勉強しているし
そこで皆様の仏教知識と私の仏教知識はなんか違うんですね
そういうふうなところを個性と言うんですね
例えば 3人集めて先生を呼んで仏教を学びます
と じゃあある一つの経典を学びましょうと授業始まる
クラス始まりますね それで先生にもその経典の知識があって
クラス終わったらこの 3人の友達にもその経典の内容はわかるんですね
同じ？同じじゃないんです
それぞれ人の同じポイントなんですけど
例えば有名な言葉あるでサバパパサカラナ
悪はすべて犯さないこと
それについて勉強する
3人と悪はすべての悪は犯さないこと
わかってますけど なんかどこかでわかり方が違うんですね
それはそれは個性というんです
だから無常があって個性も成り立ってるんです
自我っていうのは変なラベルなんですね
ラベル貼らないところラベル貼っちゃったんですね
それだけ はい  まあすいません
また長松さん お願いします
あの医療の問題でちょっとお聞きしたいんですが
病気の医療ですね 例えば東洋的な医療と西洋的な医療がありまして
例えば細胞の中のがん細胞ができた
それを西洋医学的にはいい細胞と悪い細胞で
悪い細胞を切り取るっていうようなことをよくやってますが
選択する人によっては
それは切らないで 東洋医療的にいい細胞に変化していくようなことを期待して
いろいろ手を尽くすというようなこと考えられますが
仏教的にはどちらを選択されるでしょうか
仏教的にはね 勝手にしなさいなんですけど
どうしたって死ぬんだからね
で 生きていきたいという気持ちがあると
かなり厳しい選択になりますよ
どうしたってもう死にますからね
まあ適当で気楽に選択できます
だから本当に仏教的には切り取りたければ切り取り取ってください
でもあんた その分は結構ひどい目にあいますよと
東洋的な医療で細胞をいい細胞に入れ替えと思ったらいいんだけど
長い時間かかりますよと
その間で先に死んじゃう可能性もありますよと
結局どちらでも同じですから
もう勝手にしなさいなんですね
だから あまりこの 気楽にアプローチするのね
仏教ではね 無常だから変えること可能なら変えてもいい
だから知識あれば 区別能力あれば変える技も見つかりますよ
ですから この 今も治療できない病気もあるしね
がんはいまだに治療できない病気の一つでしょ
だからそこでこの精神的にストレス受け取れない
ストレスしない 困らない
悩まない どうせ無常だから
だから だから私は体に調べてね
ここからここは異常ですよと言われる場合は
そうですかね なるほど
まあ不思議もないと私ね
へっちゃらで言うんですね
ああ なるほど こんなの不思議でもないんだと
医者が困るんで これで何とかしなくちゃとかね
私にはないんです 逆に
まあ先生に何とかできるならば
まあ言う通りに従いますけど
できなかったらいいよ
別にと どうせ壊れますからと
だからその気楽さがあればありがたいなと思いますね
精神的に生きていきたい
生きていきたいというこの法則違反の気持ちがあると
薬の効き目がすごく悪くなるんです
例えば副作用のある薬
たくさん西洋にあるでしょ
東洋では副作用はないんだから
薬にはね でも西洋にはよくあるんですね
この副作用といっても
この精神的な問題なんですよ
ほとんど だから遺伝的に副作用ある場合は
最初から薬あげません
医者は 最初からあなたにこの薬合いませんと別な薬あげるんです
だから遺伝子的に肉体には薬合わない副作用激しいんだったら
医者は薬くれません それでどんな薬も副作用あるんですが
なんである人に副作用見れたり見えなかったり
落ち着いているかいないかなんですよ
だからそんなくだらん薬飲んでるんだから
まあ仕方がありませんねという感じでいると
副作用もなくなっちゃうんです
それ 副作用をなくすために私は冷静にいれそうと思ったらアウト
それはあんたわがままありすぎ
生きていきたいでしょうね
そうすると機能しないんで難しいね
そこら辺は だから命を捨てるんです
捨てた方が楽なんです
命を捨てるものなんです
幸福 頑張る そこで生きてる間は幸福で
最終的には生きていなくたっても幸福という涅槃を作る
命がなくても幸福 それは涅槃と呼んで
だからわからない 命がなくても涅槃というのはね
わからないでしょ それはわからないんです
わからないんだけど 本当にもう経験できる境地です
えーと そんなもんです
だから私には明確な答えは出せないんです
どちらでも 東洋西洋と関係なく
医療っていうのは悪くないが悪いんですね
だってご飯も同じことでしょう
ご飯が悪くないんだけど
ご飯のせいで病気 病気になるんだからね
世の中ってそんなもんなんです
我々が食べる食べ物は
命を支えてくれると同時に命を壊してもいく
薬は病気を治してくれると同時に
細胞に迷惑をかける で
東洋医学ではという 私はインドの医学世界から言いますけど
ある哲学があるんですね
医者っていうのは あのお坊さんと同じ仕事なんですね
給料もらってやる仕事じゃないんです
そこで宗教っていうのは日本と違って
宗教っていうのは朝から晩まで必要なものでしょ
生き方ですからね 毎日必要なんです
怒ってはいけませんしね
怒ってはいけないというのは毎日のことでしょ
欲張ってはいけませんというのは
お母さんが死んでからですかね
じゃないでしょ 毎日でしょ
だから宗教っていうのは毎日朝晩必要なものなんです
ですから 宗教家と医者が同じ
医者の仕事っていうのは毎日必要なんです
だから治療して金をもらうことは不可能になっちゃうんですね
ということは 細胞をどう管理するのかということを仕事なんです
だからアーユルヴェーダの場合は
病気 なる必要ないんです
治療するんです 治療は何なのかというと
あんたね これとこれ一緒に食べるなよと
この野菜は夜食べるなよと
この野菜を食べたければ朝食べなさいと
そういう風に食べるものの量と組み合わせを教えているんです
いろいろ だから生き方を教える
そうすると細胞は自然法則で衰えて死ぬ
もし人が病気になったら
医者の失敗 医者の失敗です
だから西洋と思考が違うんです
医者住んでいる村で誰かにね
風邪が引いて 高熱出して体震えやってもうもう意識も朦朧で大変
医者が悪い それで森に入ったところで
何か何か知らない食べ物を食べた
医者がそれでも医者が悪いと
森に入ったっても医者がアドバイスしてるんだからね
だからもう森に入った人がこの食べ物美味しそうに見えるんだけど
一応先生に聞いてから食べますと
なければよかったのにね
はい そういうことで 私は何が言いたいかというのは
我々の生活習慣がどうしても感情がある
煩悩がある 欲がある 怒りがある
嫉妬がある もうあるでしょうに
そんなのは だから細胞の管理がうまくいかないんですね
それで病気にはなります
そこで何とかできれば何とかしてください
できなかったらもう放っておいてくださいと
治療を受けても受けなくても死ぬから大丈夫ですと
何も損はしていないんだと
いうスタンスなんです
ありがとうございました
はい なぜ人間が 100%鍵を外せるとおっしゃったんですけど
無我に体感 無我を体感できることということで解釈したんですけれども
人間は一番自我にとらわれやすい生命だと思うんですよ
肉体もない 悪い感情もない
そういう生命っていうのは
自我にとらわれないような印象があるんですけれども
あとは子供だったり 動物も自我
煩悩 欲というものが少ない
小さいように見えるんですけど
なぜ人間だけがそういった鍵を外せるのか
無我を体感できる何か条件
例えばハードル 肉体的な
あと心の条件だったりっていうのは何かあるんでしょうか？ 何もないんですが
鍵を人間だけが外せずいたっても
どんな生命にも同じ鍵なんですね
つけているのは 一応念のためにロックしているんです
だから開けようとするならば
どんな生命にも開けられるはずですけどね
理論的な可能性だけなんですよ
そちらになるのは だから人間に鍵を外せるならば
どんな生命にも外せますよ
それは理論的に可能だけの話で
論理的にね 実行できるかというと
実行できないんですね
人間にできないのはできた理由は
ヘビは体の絞る力と顎が剥がれる顎です
エビの大きな大きいもの
どんな大きいもの食えるでしょ？それと毒を持っていて
それで生きているんですね
だからその辺に限った分別区別能力をプログラムインストールしているんです
人間の場合は毒がないし
顎はついているしね だから大きいものは食えないしね
足が弱いしね 走れない
体力ないんですね 時々犬がぶつけてきたっても
人間負けますね 体力ないんですね
すごい弱い 弱いんだけど
業がちゃんと人間として成長して死ぬまでのプログラムを入れるんですね
そこで人間が思考と脳を使いなさいということになったんです
だから ヘビの毒の代わりに
我々にはね 大脳があるんで
それだけ だからコブラよりも世界には結構毒撒いてるでしょ
我々は 作っているんだからね
だからこの脳で見る聞くいろんなことをしているんだから
これ心の働きですけど
脳という臓器 道具使っているし
まあそういうところで見るならば
まあ見るものは見ようかなとか
特に動物は必要なことしか見ない
人間には必要でないものでも見ちゃうんですね
能力あるんだから だって結構能力あるでしょ
脳に だからカラスは必要なものしか見てないんです
必要なものは自分の命を支えるか危険かそれだけ
人間が命を支えることなくても
ぼけーっと見ているしね
別に危険妙ということないでしょ？何が危険か妙妙とやらないんです
何が私の命を助けてくれるか妙
それもないんです ただ見ていいなと
だから耳などなど 我々はもうそうやってこの存在欲と違っても使えるようになっているんです
だから数学できるようになっちゃったんです
あれで生きていられないんだけど
なんとか使います 関係ないのに結構やっています
あれ ああいうことできるんだから
これはもう拡大できるようになっちゃってね
そこで鍵が外せますね
他の生命にはティーアティカリ
別にロックしているだけ
あれ 飛行機に乗ったらあのバッケルロックするでしょ
ベルトをね あれあれ バカ上げれば誰だって開けますよ
でも 例えばちっちゃな子供にバカルつけておく
自分ではできない それを開けることは
時々金ある人はね 機内に自分のペットを持っていく
お金払っちゃえばもうなんかなんとか中で持っていくことはできるみたいんですね
それでもバカベルトつけなくちゃあかんですね
同じベルトですけど あれは外せませんね
誰かやってくれない限りは
まあそんな程度なんですね
次あんたが言ったのは
子供に人間だけ煩悩あるとかね
自我強いとかね それはないんですよ
人間が思考妄想するんだから
強烈にこの自我が硬くなるだけ
誰にだって自我エゴあるんです
赤ちゃんに何か自我がない
煩悩がないように見えるのは
何も余計なことを考えていないからなんです
だから可愛いしね 嫌なことだったらすぐ泣いちゃうし
すぐ笑っちゃうし ないわけじゃないんですね
コンクリートかけてないんです
固めてないんですね 人間が思考妄想で固めていくんですね
それだけです 他は答えなかったポイントあった
あの誰か指名してたか見えなかったんだけど
全部答えていただきました
ありがとうございます
はいはい  では ちょうど時間になりましたので
これで終了にしたいと思います
じゃあ最後の これも慈悲の瞑想みたいな文章ですが
まずパーリ語で一緒に唱えてください
それから日本語をやります
ドゥッカッパッターチェニン ドゥッカ
バーヤン パッターチェ ニン バーヤー
ソーカッパッターチェ ニン ソーカ
ホントゥ サンディッピ パーニノー
苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消え去りますように
悲しむものの悲しみが癒されますように
すべての生命がかくのごとくありますように
はい ありがとうございます
はい マハーサンスありがとうございました
それではこれで七月の月例講演会終了いたします
皆様 気をつけてお帰りください